no I am NOT going to talk about the
international trailer for Star Wars
because I refuse to watch it I have seen
enough marketing I know I'm going to see
this movie I do not want to know any
more than I already know the trailer
that I do want to talk about however is
the one for warcraft because this is a
film that I've been very cautiously
keeping my eye on because I keep I keep
waiting for a good video game movie and
actually I've got reasons fairly deep
seated ones at this point for why I
think that actually can't happen why
will never get one and that's a video on
a conversation I'll probably have a
little later on but the reasons that i
have for why we have not gotten one and
why I'm afraid we may never get one this
could have been the exception because
what works with Warcraft in terms of
presenting it is that Warcraft has got a
ton of lore but people outside the
hardcore gaming fans of that particular
franchise don't really necessarily know
the story and I feel like there's enough
room where you just get if you get
wrapped up in the world enough that they
can make the kind of adjustments they
need you to make the story work on film
so having seen the trailer how do I feel
about it yeah now granted that a lot of
this isn't based on story it's based off
just the visuals cuz that's primarily
what the trailer is but I gotta tell you
that as far as I'm concerned this this
trailer and from a visual aspect this
movie has one job and that is to look
better than a blizzard cutscene now
that's I'm not saying that facetiously
that's actually a fairly high bar to
clear because Blizzard probably does
some of the best cutscenes in the
business but this needs to look better
than that I need to feel like I am
getting a bigger better different
experience than just going on YouTube
and watching all of the cutscenes back
to back to back and watching that I
don't get that at all I think a lot of
it comes down to two things 1i I don't
like the decision that they went motion
capture and CGI with the orcs because
these don't look any better than they do
in the cutscenes there was just that was
very little I saw about this that did
not feel Jeanette
I mean I'm hoping you could save
yourself in terms of approach because
the approach as I understand it is this
Connie of almost equal time to the
humans and the orcs and that's a that's
a fairly ballsy way as opposed to just
going here's the good guys here's the
bad guys so maybe that'll you know get
it going and maybe that'll save it but
just going off the trailer it doesn't
grab me and I mean and I wish that
somebody would figure out a way to shoot
these sort of epic fantasy worlds that
doesn't do it the same way Lord of the
Rings does with the big sweeping reveal
shots I mean I don't know how else you
do it i'm not a cinematographer i'm not
a director but somebody's got to figure
out another way to do it cuz that shot
of that city i can't look at that and
not think that's ministère a--the and
that's really got nothing to do with the
design and the aesthetic of the place
somebody's just gotta figure out a
different way of shooting it that isn't
the way Peter Jackson's shot these
things again I would like to think that
the story aspect of this movie has the
potential to save it but if it looks
like this it's gonna feel like it's a
two-hour cutscene it's no bigger no
grander know better than that maybe
that's you know just more thumbs up to
blizzard for making awesome cutscenes
that a full length movie can't do any
better than I don't know but have you
seen the first trailer for the warcraft
film what were your thoughts on it
whatever they were drop something down
in the comments and let's talk about it
until next time this council is
adjourned